Joe Biden swamps the competition in
South Carolina Super Tuesday approaches
and that right soon and the Trump
administration deals with fallout from
the spread of corona virus I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe at expressvpn calm /pan by
the way you may have noticed that
everybody is panicked about coronavirus
I mean the stock market dropped four
thousand two points a last week lost
number ten percent of its value which
counts as a stock market correction at
that point you may have been thinking oh
I really should have listened to Ben and
diversified into precious metals that is
correct you should have because the fact
is that with volatility is high and it
is as it is with the possibility of
Black Swan events like coronavirus with
uncertainty coming from places like
China and from Europe policies that you
can't control why would you not be
diversified at least a little bit into
precious metals again the stock market
dropped too much last week and gold rose
concomitant Lee because that is the way
the stock market works when there's
uncertainty it is good to be invested in
something hard too precious asset like
precious metals and Birch gold group can
make that happen for you right now coal
Birch gold right now convert your
traditional IRA or 401k into a precious
metals IRA if that's something you're
interested in hedge against what we've
seen in the past week alone if you
haven't taken the first step of
requesting a free information can on
gold you should know this is not a
complicated process it's very simple you
can ask all your questions get all your
answers birch gold will go to work and
make things super simple for you they'll
have a conversation with you you can
determine if precious metals make sense
for you and really again everybody
should have some of their money in
precious metals do not wait until the
market drops more to protect your
hard-earned savings text Ben - 47 47 47
today to see how simple and
straightforward this move can be for you
again text my name Ben 247 and 4747
that's Ben - 47 47 47 when it comes to
precious metals investing the people I
trust are the folks over at Birch gold
by the thousands of other satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews a
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau text Ben - 47 47 47 for more
information all righty so tomorrow is
Super Tuesday and it's gonna be super
it's very very Super Tuesday why well
because we finally have a competition
according to 538 there is now a
two-thirds chance of an open convention
in the Democratic Party which is a
nightmare scenario for the Democrats
because right now the way that 538 has
this thing gamed out
according to their latest poll
statistics in their their latest metrics
they believe that Sanders will go in to
the convention the Democratic convention
with a slight plurality of delegates
when I say slight I mean super duper
slight when you look at the way they are
they're gaming this out they say in the
remaining 10,000 simulations they run
tons of simulations then they sort of
average the simulations they're
suggesting that Bernie Sanders would end
up with around 1,600 delegates he needs
2000 to clinch the nomination he'd end
up about 16 hundred delegates Joe Biden
would end up with about 1450 Michael
Bloomberg could end up about 600
delegates and Elizabeth Warren would end
up with about 239 delegates which means
that Bloomberg and Biden combined would
be just about like right at 2,000
delegates and Sanders and Warren
combined would be at like 1,900
delegates so how exactly does that play
out who the hell knows because
presumably Warren throws her support to
Bernie Sanders and Michael Bloomberg
throws his support to Joe Biden on the
second ballot and then you have the
moderate ticket that overcomes the
Bernie ticket but the problem is that
the Bernie ticket then walks out and
most of his voters don't go and vote for
Joe Biden's they don't like Joe Biden so
it's a real disaster area inside the
Democratic Party things got a lot more
complicated with Joe Biden winning big
in South Carolina over the weekend and a
few things became obvious one black
audience is not resonating to Bernie
Sanders right but Bernie does real well
in very white states did very well in
Iowa very well in New Hampshire there's
a lot of talk about how he did well with
Latino audiences but Latino audiences
are not quite as polarized among
Democratic candidates as black audiences
are obviously because Joe Biden ran away
just skunked Bernie and a lot of that
has to do with the fact that the black
electorate in places like South Carolina
is a church-going electorate and Bernie
is overtly non-religious not only
overtly non-religious anti religious in
many cases it's not just that he talked
about how he's Jewish because that
really has no impact he is not Jewish in
any real sense other than the ethnic
he's certainly not religiously Jewish he
is not culturally Jewish like there's
nothing about him is Jewish other than
the fact that he was born into a Jewish
family which makes him technically
ethnically Jewish but that's not gonna
play extraordinarily well in
church-going States is his sort of overt
atheism and socialism those are not
gonna play great in states like South
Carolina where Joe Biden is seen as more
of a consensus pick Joe Biden was
resonating in South Carolina and he blew
out I mean blue out Bernie Sanders and
the fact of the matter is this was meant
to be it was thought this is gonna be a
close race the conventional wisdom which
I had largely bought into prior to the
kind of late-breaking polls last week is
that Joe Biden had collapsed in the
first three states you can't lose the
first three states this way and then
have a massive comeback victory the
problem is that the electorate is so
different in South Carolina
demographically than the electorate is
in any of the first three states but
apparently you can apparently you can
have something like a South Carolina
firewall and so Joe Biden for the first
time actually demonstrates that a
firewall works so he just kills the
competition he won nearly 50% of the
vote in South Carolina and Bernie just
got skunked in South Carolina the final
results in in South Carolina for for the
Democrats brutal 48 percent for Joe
Biden 48.4% he almost he more than
doubled up Bernie Bernie got nineteen
point nine percent
Tom Styer got eleven point three percent
and Pete Budaj got eight point two
percent and Biden was was really excited
about all this 139 delegates to Bernie
Sanders is 13 he's running in
extraordinarily narrow delegate gap to
Bernie he's down by like five delegates
going into Super Tuesday Super Tuesday
of course have hundreds and hundreds of
delegates who are up for grabs 1,200
1,300 delegates or up for grabs there's
no question that Biden has the momentum
going into Super Tuesday Joe Biden was
pretty celebratory about it he should be
it's the first Democratic primaries ever
won he's run for president three times
the first Democratic primary he's ever
won anyone going away by the way if
Barack Obama were to sound even a mild
note of endorsement of Bernie of Biden
at this point which is what he should do
because basically this race is now down
to Biden and Bernie my Bloomberg does
not have a path to the nomination
there's no way that Bloomberg ends up
with either plurality of the delegates
or the Bloomberg ends up with a majority
of the delegates so that means it's a
two-man race why Obama wouldn't come out
here's enough to endorse Biden just say
I trust Joe Joe's wonderful right does
even have to overtly endorse him just
say some kind words right before Super
Tuesday it would make a big difference
because one of the things that made a
huge difference apparently was Jim
Clyburn in South Carolina getting behind
Joe Biden apparently 25% by exit polls
of the people who voted in that primary
said that Jim Clyburn --zz endorsement
of Joe Biden made a big difference
there's a reason that Joe Biden is also
going around
seeking endorsements major political
figures in states like Virginia he got
the endorsement from Senator Tim Kaine
and the endorsement from former Governor
Terry McAuliffe in Virginia over the
weekend as well so he's hoping to run up
the scores in the various southern
states where there's a heavy black
population because again there is this
massive demographic gap in the
Democratic Party between upper class
white liberals and young white liberals
who apparently really like Bernie
Sanders and everybody else who really
likes Joe Biden so Biden at his rally on
Saturday night very excited says
Democrats want a Democratic nominee we
don't want a socialist won the
Democratic nominee is not protecting the
poor any chance for the middle class get
restored
not raise their taxes he may keep the
promises we make then join us and if the
Democrats want a nominee who's a
Democrat man and that is him saying this
guy's too radical you should not do now
here's the thing if Biden comes away
from Super Tuesday anywhere within
remote distance of Bernie he ends up
with the floor out of a plurality of the
delegates so tomorrow matters an awful
lot because once this is down to a
two-man race let's say Bloomberg
underperforms so what's what's weird
about the way that the Democratic
primaries work for folks who don't
understand the process the Republican
primaries if you and a plurality of the
votes in a state you win the entirety of
the delegates this is how Donald Trump
never won more than 50% in a state
through the vast majority the primaries
but ended up with a majority of the
delegates because he was winning 30 35 %
but it was enough to win and because it
was enough to win he won all the
delegates rights means above them with a
majority of the delegates at the
convention Democrats don't work that way
all of their primaries are proportional
representation that means that if Joe
Biden wins 30 percent in Bernie wins 20
percent then Joe Biden wins 30 percent
of the delegates in Joba and Bernie wins
20 percent of the delegates now there is
one exception there's a cut-off if you
win 10 percent of the votes in a
particular state that's below the cutoff
you have to have 15 percent of the votes
in a particular state like California in
order to win any delegates at all
and in California we're gonna examine
the state by state in just a moment in
California that's gonna make an awful
lot of difference because California is
the most delegate rich State for the
Democrats if Joe Biden finishes at 12%
it's a disaster for him if he finishes
at 16%
and Bernie wins 35% that's still not a
disaster for Joe Biden but bottom line
is this if Super Tuesday ends up
relatively even with Biden just like a
slight downward motion with let's say
that Bernie has 600 delegates and Biden
has 560 delegates or something what
you're going to end up with is Biden as
the nominee and the reason you end up
with Biden as the nominee is as the
field consolidates all the money's gonna
push behind Biden you're headed into a
bunch of delegate rich states like
Florida where Biden is likely to swamp
Bernie so this thing is actually a race
now it's actually a race Biden was
pushing over the weekend pushing very
hard he said Bernie can't win over the
weekend he of course is making a case
that this is his entire case is entire
cases I'm electable against Trump and
Bernie is not I can win and I can bring
along Democratic victories up and down
the state I can keep the United States
said I can win the United States Senate
at the top of the ticket I can keep the
house and increase the number in the
house I can go into every state in the
nation I can go into purple states and
we can win I can win in places where I
don't think Bernie can win in the
general election and that is his case
that's his case now as we will see
there's still a bit of a delusion to
Biden right that he's running a strong
campaign or they're just gonna lock this
thing up before the before the end of
the primary season or that he even knows
what he's talking about right there
serious problems at the Biden campaign
namely trouble by well that's that in
just a moment but then we're gonna
examine the field consolidating because
people judge out Tom Styer out Elizabeth
Warren hanging around for no reason just
like John Kasich in 2016 for some odd
reason she thinks that she's gonna be
the nominee for no one understands why
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the second
amendment so the reality is that as we
live in a country with an ever growing
government as we live in a country where
it seems like a lot of the members of
the population want to disarm other
members of the population the Second
Amendment becomes ever more valuable
because the Second Amendment is the
great protector of all of the other
rights in the Constitution I obviously
believe this so do the folks over at
Bravo company manufacturing owning the
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building a rifle is no different
starting in a garage by Marine veteran
more than two decades ago bravo company
manufacturing builds a
professional-grade product built to
combat standards that's because BCM
believes the same level of protection
should be provided to every American
regardless whether there are private
or a professional the people of BCM
assume when a rifle leaves their shop it
will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas so every components of a BCM
rifle is hand assembled and tested to a
life-saving standard the people of ECM
feel it's the moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that will not
fail when it is not just a paper target
BCM also works with leading instructors
of marksmanship from top levels of
America's Special Ops forces from Marine
Corps force reconnaissance to US Army
Special Ops forces teaching you the
skills necessary to defend yourself your
family or others I own firearms to
protect my rights and protect my family
you should too if you're a responsible
citizen to learn more about Bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm you can discover
more about their products special offers
upcoming news that is Bravo Company MFG
comm you can also check out their
awesome videos meet the people who make
their products at youtube.com slash
Bravo company USA get the best gun on
market Bravo Company MFG how come
they've all sorts of other gear you want
to check out Bravo Company MFG dot-com
okay so joe biden did have a big win in
south carolina he does have momentum
serious momentum going into Super
Tuesday we're going to examine that in
just a second but well Joe Biden still
has flaws in his campaign and when Joe
Biden says for example over the weekend
he said I can win this before the
convention no he can he can he basically
has no shot of winning this thing before
the convention according to 538 his shot
of winning a majority of delegates
before the convention is like 1 in 7
Bernie Sanders by the way down to one in
five as 538 estimates two-thirds chance
that it's an open convention which is
again a disaster area for Democrats can
you imagine how mad the Bernie bros will
be if Bernie walks in with a with a
plurality of the delegates like a
hundred more delegates than Joe Biden
and biden walks out the nomination can
you imagine the insanity that's gonna
break out in the democratic party halls
can you imagine how bad it'll be
conversely if they hand it to Bernie and
Biden and Bloomberg have combined two
hundred more delegates than Bernie and
Warren can you imagine how the moderate
wing is gonna react to all of that I
mean that the chaos inside the
convention is gonna be madness here is
Joe Biden trying to whistle through the
graveyard saying he can win before the
convention do you think you can win this
primary before the convention or do you
think is inevitable that it's inevitable
though that you and Sanders may have to
work this out at the convention I think
I do win it before the convention but
again I I'm not looked all I know is I
think we're moving into a constituencies
that are constituencies when they hear
me they've always been mine man that
that's him basically saying no we're
gonna we're gonna go all the way to the
convention by the way what's up can he
offered a Bernie that is going to
satisfy Bernie what's gonna make him UN
ambassador well what exactly him Biden
offered a Bernie that is going to make
Bernie quiescent about all of this
Bernie has a movement there's no reason
for Bernie to go into a Biden
administration there's no reason for him
to tie his tie his shoelaces to Joe
Biden's shoelaces right then he gets
none of the credit if Joe Biden wins and
all of the blame if Joe Biden loses like
there isn't
it's an unbridgeable gap inside the
Democratic Party meanwhile Joe Biden
again whistling past the graveyard
saying that the lack of Barack Obama's
endorsement isn't hurting him it is I
mean a Barack Obama came out tomorrow
and endorsed him Biden win the
nomination and even win it walking away
but Obama's not getting involved which
is truly an amazing spectacle that Obama
who hates Sanders and thinks that
Sanders is a tool bad because he is and
who supposedly likes Joe Biden won't
come out at this point
in a highly contested primary season and
just say I like Joe doesn't have to
endorse him doesn't even have to say I'd
vote for Joe I mean he should say I vote
for Joe over Sanders but who are you
voting for Barack I'm voting for Joe
like why wouldn't he just say that it's
pretty incredible that he's been silent
about all of this here is Joe Biden
suggesting that it's not a problem for
him that Obama hasn't endorsed him in
her tea man I don't think it's time he
and I have talked about this in the very
beginning I have to earn this in my own
remember George the first thing
everybody said when I announced the
opposition the Democratic opposition
said well Biden feels entitled because
he's vice president imagine had the
president endorsed me would've mo
Biden's in title because it he think he
thinks he's entitled because the bottom
line is that the only reason that
anybody takes Joe Biden remotely
seriously is because Barack Obama was
the president and Joe Biden was his Vice
President Joe Biden's run for president
twice before not received a single
electoral vote not one so not one
delegate so obviously this is all about
Obama meanwhile again the biggest threat
to Joe Biden is the fact that he is Joe
Biden right the biggest upside to Joe
Biden for Democrats is that he has the
patina of the sort of shine of Barack
Obama on him the halo of Barack Obama on
him if you were not bad he would be
nothing because
this is a guy who bumbles and fumbles
and he's terrible right here was Joe
Biden yesterday confusing Ebola with
coronavirus down on health care by
building on Obamacare with a Biden
Medicare option in it I can do this in
terms of Ebola excuse me in terms of
dealing with the issues that relate to
what we put together when we faced
epidemic of Ebola what the hell is even
talking about I mean it like there's
just not a lot going on in that head
meanwhile the field is consolidating
people judges ended his run people to
judge was the most talented politician
in this field he also was the guy who
was smart enough to get out now because
he recognized that if you were to stay
in and complicate this if you were to
split votes if you were to take away a
few delegates from Joe Biden and then be
blamed for Bernie Sanders's rise then it
would be very bad for him now here's the
problem for Budi judge people keep
saying he'll be able to run for
president again it'll all be fine now
this is pretty much it for people to
judge because unless he has appointed to
some sort of role inside a democratic
administration he has no pathway to
glory he's in Indiana unless he
carpet-bags it over to New York or
carpet-bags and over to Massachusetts he
ain't going anywhere in Indiana
Indiana's a red state it's increasingly
red when he ran statewide he lost by 20
points so the problem for people who to
judge is that Budi judge really had no
upward trajectory inside his own state
which is why he ran as mayor of South
Bend Indiana what's he just gonna stay
mayor of South Bend Indiana and then run
for president again so Budaj edge
obviously made a lot of waves because
he's gay yeah I mean again let's be real
about this if you were a straight man he
certainly wouldn't have made the sort of
national waves that he did he's a very
talented guy he is smuggling awful I
mean people who judges the guy who is
also lecturing Americans about how they
were bad Christians if they didn't agree
with his take on abortion and same-sex
marriage was pat which is patently crazy
but what he judges talented guy tell
people in democratic party who are
patting him on the head and saying well
he'll be back
someday he'll be back someday not unless
he's appointed to Secretary of Defense
otherwise people who judges day in the
sunshine is over yes at age 38 because
again he has no upper trajectory inside
of his states unless he carpet-bags it
or unless he's appointed inside a
Democratic administration it's over for
him but he understands that his smart
role is to get out again the smartest
politician in the race was Buddha judge
he made the smartest move now which is
get out right now don't wait until
things get complicated meanwhile the
dummy Elizabeth Warren is staying in to
complicate thing for Bernie Sanders
which is kind of fascinating so
what a judge is being treated with all
sorts of plaudits this morning despite
the fact that he really is insufferable
on a wide variety of levels yesterday he
announced that he was dropping out
because he has to help the new
Democratic nominee speaking from South
Bend recognized that at this point in
the race the best way to keep faith with
those goals and ideals it's to step
aside and help bring our party and our
country together so tonight I am making
the difficult decision to suspend my
campaign for the presidency I will no
longer seek to be the 2020 Democratic
nominee for president but I will do
everything in my power to ensure that we
have a new Democratic president come
January he invited her trading
voicemails by the way so there's a
significant possibility that after Super
Tuesday you could see people if it's
competitive you could see people who
judge jump into the Biden camp and and
you could see Biden presumably you know
give give bootie judge exactly what he
needs which is some sort of cabinet
appointment that's the only thing that
bootie judge has in terms of a political
future is some sort of cabinet
appointment and so him trading that to
Biden in favor of whatever level of
support bootie judge has nationally
which is not great but it's something
that would be the smart move by bootie
judge which presumably is why he was not
trading phone calls with Bernie Sanders
meanwhile Tom Steyer has also announced
that he is out the billionaire who spent
like 200 million dollars on this
campaign to win two delegates or
something this guy spent something like
$3,300 per vote in South Carolina he
announced that he was out he's gonna
throw presumably his massive massive
support behind Bernie Sanders I mean the
guy was desperately trying get a hug
from Bernie Sanders and really the
entire campaign harassed ire announcing
he was dropping out there's no question
today that this campaign we were
disappointed with where we came out I
think we got one or two delegates from
congressional districts which I thank
South Carolina for and the people but I
said if I didn't see a path to winning
that I'd suspend my campaign and
honestly I can't see a path where I can
win the presidency so am I gonna
continue to work on every single one of
these issues yes of course I am okay so
here is where we now stand
we have a consolidation of the field
booty dredges out he was expected by 538
to win about 50 delegates over the
course of the of the Super Tuesday
contests he will win some delegates
anyway because there's all this early
voting and early vote this just shows
you why early voting is stupid some
300,000 people have already cast ballots
in California and many of them have cast
ballots for people who are not even on
the ballot anymore right people who are
not going to matter people like people
you judge so that that's pretty amazing
but let's assume that most of Buddha
judges delegates move over to Biden well
that means that according to 538 looking
at the numbers that they are putting
forth this is the average number of
delegates each Democratic presidential
candidate is forecasted to receive from
each Super Tuesday contests according to
their 5:30 a primary forecast this would
be as of 11:30 a.m. Eastern yesterday
they were suggesting that Sanders would
walk away with about 540 delegates from
Super Tuesday that Biden would walk away
with about 395 that Bloomberg would walk
without 194 and then Budi judge would
walk away with 50 and Warren with 133
well Bloomberg and Buddha judge it
really depends on whether you think the
Bloomberg's numbers are actually real
and I've serious doubts that Bloomberg's
numbers are real I think that Bloomberg
is gonna perform once he's on the ballot
almost exactly like Tom Steyer did
Thomas Tyrel was running 15 to 20
percent in South Carolina
once he was actually on the ballot in
South Carolina and people were forced to
choose and they recognized that steyr
was not a viable candidate then they
just didn't vote for him he got 11
percent of the vote and most of that
went to other candidates I think you're
gonna see the same thing happen with
Michael Bloomberg who is fully
delusional at this point Bloomberg is
just walking around as though he has a
shot at the nomination he had one narrow
path his narrow path was that Biden
completely collapsed in South Carolina
at Bernie 1 or came close to winning and
that then he could call on Joe Biden to
drop out because it's true that if you
want to win a majority of the delegates
that has to be consolidation behind one
candidate the problem right now is that
Biden just showed signs of life and not
just road signs what's your serious life
in South Carolina well that means that
Bloomberg and Biden are now splitting a
lane and so assume for a second that
Bloomberg were not in the race
presumably those 195 delegates somewhere
in that neighborhood none of those
people are gonna go to Bernie presumably
nearly all of those people would have
gone to Joe Biden well if those
delegates had moved over to Joe Biden
guess who you're in and elegant leader
would have been Joe Biden by a pretty
significant margin so I think that
a lot of what happens on Super Tuesday
is dependent on where Bloomberg stands
in a lot of the southern states because
remember if Bloomberg wins below 15
percent in those states those delegates
don't go to Bloomberg instead a lot of
those delegates kick up to the
front-runner Joe Biden so I think that
Biden is actually gonna outperform on
Super Tuesday this is my this is my my
edgy prediction I think that Biden is
going to over perform on Super Tuesday I
think that South Carolina shows people
he's viable I think he's gonna get a lot
of endorsements today and early tomorrow
I think that in southern states he's
absolutely gonna clean up I think in
California he is going I think he's
going to surpass the the delegate margin
in California necessary to gain some
delegates I think that the the race is
going to be pretty close coming out of
Super Tuesday I do not think this is a
Bernie Sanders walk walk over come Super
Tuesday so I mean just one second I'm
gonna get to some of the actual polling
from the various Super Tuesday states
cuz the polling is pretty sporadic and a
lot of these states but we're gonna
explain which states are up and how many
delegates they have and who is likely to
win those states we're gonna get to all
of that in just one second first it's
hard to plan for the future man it is
hard to plan for the future
it's particularly hard to plan for your
own death because who the hell knows
what I mean that's something that we all
worry about we all stay up nights
worrying about but one thing is certain
you should make sure that your family is
taken care of in case god forbid
something happens to you and this is why
you ought to have life insurance if
you're a responsible adult your family
needs a stream of income if god forbid
something happens to you this is why you
should go over to policy genius right
now and go get life insurance policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price you could save
fifteen hundred bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies it's very important
to get life insurance that doesn't mean
it needs to be difficult to get yet
enough to do this through word of mouth
and get a bad deal just because a friend
told you about a life insurance policy
from their friend instead why don't you
competitively shop the same way you
would for any decent product once you
apply the policy genius team handles all
the paperwork and the red tape for free
and policy genius doesn't just do life
insurance they do all sorts of insurance
home insurance auto insurance disability
insurance if life doesn't play out the
way that you expected well the least you
can do is get the insurance to make sure
that your family is taken care of check
them out at policy genius com policy
genius everybody gets the future wrong
better get life insurance right that's
policy genius.com
okay so let's go through some of these
Super Tuesday states you have all the
you need it can play with these numbers
yourself one of the fun things to do if
you're very bored at work today is you
can go oh they're a bunch of delegate
calendars calculators and you can go in
and you can sort of estimate what
percentage of the vote
you think various candidates are going
to win in a lot of these states okay so
the big prize on Super Tuesday is of
course California the problem is that
the polls don't close until 8 p.m.
Pacific time and we're not even gonna
see results in California until very
late so that cuts in favor of Joe Biden
why because that is Bernie's biggest
winning state right if Bernie does real
well in California we're not going to
know until the next day are you really
not gonna know it's that means that if
Biden shows a lot of momentum in the
other states then he could get a lot of
big headlines out of Super Tuesday night
because again the biggest prize on the
map is Bernie Bernie Bernie is
California and California is going to
show up really late like 11:00 p.m.
Eastern is when the polls close
so Latinos are expected to make about
30% of the electorate Sanders won
Latinos overwhelmingly in Nevada the
suggestion is he might run up the score
with them in California as well but it
is also necessary to say that in Nevada
everybody is heavily unionized it is
also necessary to say that in Nevada
it's a much smaller state I mean the
sample size itself is much smaller so
Sanders did lose California to Hillary
Clinton in 2016 he spent a ton of money
or spent about seven million bucks on
ads according to NPR Biden has spent no
money on California TV ads he has spent
four thousand bucks on digital ads but
apparently the early voting was fairly
slow Bloomberg is currently polling
below the 15 percent threshold required
to get delegates in all of these
contests Warren is teetering around the
delegate threshold percentage - the
question is whether she gets 15 percent
also there were no exit polls in 2016
black voters in 2008 in California were
only 7 percent of the electorate but the
California Democratic Party is
estimating the black black Americans
make about 16% of the party in the state
of California so maybe they show up in
heavy numbers so what are the polls say
about California well the most recent
poll is a poll from Emerson and it does
show Joe Biden's surpassing that 15%
I'll get threshold which is a big deal
for Joe Biden it's not about Biden
winning California it is about Biden
showing up above the 15% delegate
threshold because we're here to show up
above that 15% delegate threshold well
then he would win in a
delegates to make some serious trouble
for Bernie Bernie needs to run away with
California he needs to win 300 delegates
in California and if there are three
candidates who are above the delegate
threshold right now that is where Boren
is pulling she's also above that I would
get threshold in a lot of these states
well that is a problem for Bernie
there's a CBS YouGov poll that came out
just before the South Carolina primaries
and that one only showed Sanders up 31
19 over Biden and with Warren at 18 so
there by the way Bloomberg was getting
told Buddha judge was getting 7 to 9
percent of the vote in all of these
polls right so Buddha judge was getting
seven and that 7 kicks over to Biden
suddenly Biden is looking a lot more
viable in states like California so that
is where things stand in California
Bloomberg is running below 15% but he's
still pulling somewhere between 11 and
15 percent
how many moderate Democrats in
California now look at Bloomberg and
they go okay that guy can't win the
nomination but you know who can would be
Joe Biden so I think that Biden is gonna
over perform the polling in California I
think the Biden is going to perform 23
to 25 percent in California which would
be a big win for Biden in Texas the
Democratic primary polling in Texas
shows Sanders with a lead in the Real
Clear Politics poll average again the
latest two polls in Texas which does
have a serious number of Delegates 228
delegates at stake polling shows that
Sanders is up in average in the text in
the in the Real Clear Politics polling
average about 6%
I don't think Sanders gonna win text
setting buttons gonna win Texas I think
that I think that's gonna be the big
shock of the night is that I do not
think that Sanders is gonna pull out
Texas because the fact is that Texas
Democrats are still not as radical as
the rest of the Democratic Party across
the country they're radical in Austin
but they're not radical anywhere else
okay right now the Emerson poll shows
Sanders with 31 and Biden with 26 and
Bloomberg at 16 I don't think Bloomberg
is gonna show at 16 I don't think
Bloomberg is gonna show at 13 I think
Bloomberg's again I don't know that
bloomer he's gonna break 10% in Texas I
think blue I think the big story the
night is Bloomberg he's gonna
underperform Biden's gonna over perform
and now hold me to my dumb prediction
after it turns out I'm wrong about all
this and I would never put my own money
on my own betting because I did that in
2016 didn't work out great for me but I
have a feeling that South Carolina the
media coverage the fact that Biden's
gonna get a lot of big endorsements over
the next 48 hours I think that means
that you're gonna see Bloomberg start to
collapse because again the reason that
bloom Bloomberg was almost a
placeholder when people are polled about
Bloomberg it's a placeholder for Biden
it was people saying okay well it was
more referendum on vibe than it was on
Bloomberg so people thought that Biden
was gonna collapse they said I'm gonna
vote for Bloomberg if they think the
Biden is going to not collapse and they
say I'm gonna vote for Biden so all of
these polls are not taking into account
South Carolina and the ones that are
taking into account South Carolina are
showing a significant bump for Joe Biden
right that Emerson poll the ones that
came out they were done on Saturday and
then through Sunday those polls are
showing Biden significantly
outperforming the other polls and that's
not taking into account his South
Carolina victory except for one day of
the poll that Emerson poll that's
showing Biden up at 26% again to Sanders
is 31 even the CBS News YouGov poll in
Texas shows Sanders up 32 26 over Biden
well what about three days of great
coverage for Joe Biden what about three
days of Joe mentum coverage for Joe
Biden I think that I think Biden's gonna
pull out Texas I think that I think the
Biden is gonna over perform in Texas
which is real trouble for Bernie Sanders
then you get to North Carolina North
Carolina the problem for for Bernie in
North Carolina is that black voters
represent about a third of the
electorate 61% of voters in North
Carolina are 45 and older okay so both
groups do favor Biden the percentages of
both are lower in North Carolina than in
South Carolina but right now the polling
in in North Carolina is not reflective
of reality it just isn't
okay the polling in North Carolina right
now shows Biden up only four points on
Sanders according to East Carolina you
that came out before the South Carolina
results that's before the South Carolina
results remember in the polling averages
for South Carolina Biden was only
winning about thirty five and forty
percent of the vote he showed 48% of the
vote in South Carolina significantly
outperformed he Isle performed the 538
estimates by eight percentage points in
South Carolina I think you're gonna see
the same thing in North Carolina I think
you're gonna see Biden walk all over
Sanders in North Carolina I think you're
gonna see that Bloomberg vote collapse I
think you're gonna see Biden easily
surpass 30 percent in North Carolina I
think it's gonna be more like 35 percent
in North Carolina when it comes to
Massachusetts I think Sanders gonna win
Massachusetts walking away I do not
think it's gonna be that close right now
the polls show Sanders and Moore and
very close in Massachusetts which is
another big prize I think Sanders is
going to do much better because I think
that the Bernie bros are going to really
mobilize there not only are they really
going
mobilize I think that the Warren crowd
is gonna realize that she has no shot at
the nomination so well she may do okay I
don't think that she is going to be
competitive with Bernie I think the
Bernie takes that state my five points I
and then I think you move on to
Minnesota which is another delegate
heavy state there I think that Bernie I
think that Bernie wins but narrowly I
think the Klobuchar does show in
Minnesota she is very popular in her
home state in a way that Elizabeth
Warren isn't the Elizabeth Warren dirty
little secret Elizabeth Warren ain't
that popular in Massachusetts at least
not more popular than any normal
Democrat it's not like she's wildly more
popular than whatever placeholder
Democrat had held that Senate seat
before a Virginia is another is another
state with a heavy black population
Virginia has 99 delegates at stake unite
the country a super PAC supporting Biden
believes Biden is starting to do well
not just with black voters but with
white women over the age of 40 okay that
probably is true because Bernie does not
do particularly well there are not a lot
of good polls out of Virginia the
Virginia polling is is very weak right
now all we know in Virginia is that the
Democrat let's see the latest Democrat
polls from Virginia had Sanders and
Bloomberg and Biden basically within
spitting distance of one another that
was conducted before Bloomberg's first
debate in Las Vegas and before Joe Biden
won in South Carolina so I think that
you're going by Hillary Clinton won
two-thirds of white women in in Virginia
and she ran all over Bernie in Virginia
so I think the Biden is going to I think
if you had if you had a ballpark this
thing
assume that Biden is gonna perform it
very much like Hillary Clinton did in
count Super Tuesday she ran up a
delegate lead in 2016 I think that Biden
is going to underperform Hillary in
places like California and New York and
Massachusetts but I think that he's
going to perform almost exactly like
Hillary in a lot of these southern
states Colorado is a is a heavily Latino
state about 67 delegates at stake in
Colorado again not fantastic polling
from a lot of these from a lot of these
states Colorado is another one where
they're just not that many not not that
great polling but with that said you
know it is superb it is it plausible
that it's Kinetics competitive in some
place like Colorado yeah absolutely it's
certainly plausible
so it's bottom line is that it is a mess
right now but that mess is not
necessarily cutting in Bernie's favor so
all the talk last week was that Bernie
was gonna run away with this thing in
very short order I'm not seeing a lot of
evidence that that's gonna happen I
think that this is I I think Biden's
gonna over perform I think that that
Bernie's gonna perform exactly like he
thought I think Bloomberg is gonna be
the real story I think Bloomberg is
gonna collapse and then contact between
voters and Bloomberg is toxic for
Bloomberg by the way I'm not mentioning
Tennessee where I think Biden is really
gonna run up the score I'm not
mentioning Alabama where I think Biden
is really gonna run up the score
Oklahoma where I think Biden is going to
run up the score Arkansas or he's gonna
run up the score Utah I think that
you're gonna see Sanders win Maine
you're gonna see Sanders win Vermont
you're gonna see Sanders win but it is
not implausible to believe that Joe
Biden walks away from Super Tuesday if
he doesn't have a delegate Lee because
of California at the very least he is
very very close after Super Tuesday and
then we move on to a bunch of states
that are very very conducive for the
demo for the current former Democratic
vice president right we move into the
the rest of the primary calendar looks a
lot better for Joe Biden than it does
for Bernie Sanders I'm looking at the
the presidential election calendar right
now so here's how it goes after Super
Tuesday March 10th
you got Idaho Michigan Mississippi
Missouri North Dakota Washington
Washington is good for Bernie North
Dakota is probably good for Bernie
Idaho is probably good for Bernie
Michigan probably good for burning maybe
not that could be Biden territory
Mississippi and Missouri very very good
for Joe Biden and then you move on to
March 17th Arizona which could be but
good for Bernie but Florida which is
awful for Bernie Ohio which is probably
not great for Bernie and Illinois which
is probably not great for burning
because Chicago's in Illinois right so
this is the fact is that the this race
starts as the time goes on and as Joe
Biden remains competitive this rate
starts to tilt slowly toward Joe Biden
and away from Bernie Sanders so we open
there's a reason 538 got the open
convention possibility at a 65% 65% and
by the way in terms of their majority of
Delegates they're showing Joe they're
showing Bernie at just a 21% to get it
and 14% for
so basically they're running pretty
close to even in their average number of
delegates they expect to be one again
Bernie Sanders sixteen twelve Biden 1449
they're expecting Bloomberg's win 591 I
think that's an overestimate of
Bloomberg I think Bloomberg is gonna
fall apart
I think Bloomberg and I think the ads
the Bloomberg just taking out are
largely going to be directed not against
Joe Biden orden we directed against
Bernie Sanders so I would suspect that
at least 200 of the delegates that are
being allocated to Bloomberg right now
are instead gonna cut up to Joe Biden
so quite plausible that Biden is your
leader in the clubhouse that he wins a
plurality of Delegates which is the but
that is the best-case scenario for the
Democrats by the way the best-case
scenario for the Democrats is that Biden
has a plurality of the delegates going
into the convention that is best-case
scenario and it's not implausible it's
not implausible we're gonna know so much
more after tomorrow night after Super
Tuesday but like I say this whole thing
has been about momentum
Bernie has not been able to run up the
score except in Nevada Nevada is the
only state where ran up the score in
Iowa he underperformed
in New Hampshire he underperformed he
lost he booted judge in Iowa he barely
beat people to judge in New Hampshire
and people who judge is out of the race
now that you have an actual Democratic
candidate in Joe Biden who has actual
minority support and older voter support
I'm not I said two weeks ago I thought
the Bernie was unstoppable
that was before South Carolina South
Carolina made an awful lot of difference
and tomorrow night we are going to find
out just how much of a difference all of
that made okay in just a second we're
gonna get to Bernie Sanders who seems to
be already sort of doing the whiney
routine which is kind of interesting
like he's alright he's preemptively
whining he's not acting like a
front-runner Bernie Sanders is
comfortable being the guy in second
place because he can attack everybody
else Bernie as the front-runner books he
looks fragile
he looks radical he looks like somebody
you don't want as your frontrunner he's
the person who stands outside the party
and criticizes okay in a second we're
gonna get to that but first Super
Tuesday has come upon us an octogenarian
socialist is in the lead to face off
against President Trump now if Bernie
Sanders were to run this company
everything here would be free free
memberships free advertising free
pudding cups in reality we would then be
bankrupt nonetheless we have great
savings in store for you because we are
a capitalist company so we are going to
give you savings a better deal in
competition with others and we are going
to make money for ourselves to keep all
of our unemployable derelicts employed
right now you can become a daily why
remember for 25% off on any plan using
coupon
code never socialist I know about you
guys but savings like these always make
my tumblr overflow with leftist years
daily where members get an ad-free
website experience access to all of our
live broadcast and show library the full
three hours of the men Shapiro show
access to the mailbag and now exclusive
election insight op eds from yours truly
join us for special events like
tomorrow's Super Tuesday episode of
daily wire backstage we'll be breaking
down and covering all of the Super
Tuesday election updates in real time as
a member you can ask questions that we
will answer on the backstage at
livestream I also want to announce the
Sunday special is back we kicked off the
first episode of the season yesterday
with controversial guest Charlie Kirk
from Turning Point USA daily where
members get to watch a special bonus
content available only on daily wire.com
along with all of this of course you get
the Magnificent the irreplaceable the
singular left this year's tumbler if you
haven't already download the daily wire
app so you can get all of our great
content on the go again that is 20% off
on daily water memberships for all plans
using coupon code never socialist Super
Tuesday calls for super savings so head
on over to daily wire calm / subscribe
act now before it's too late but steely
wire calm / subscribe also we would like
to hear from you tell us who you think
will win the Democratic nomination by
texting either Biden Bernie Bloomberg or
Warren 283 408 three four zero zero
eight three four hundred and on Tuesday
night during our daily wire backstage
we'll analyze the results live again
text either Biden Bernie Bloomberg Morin
two eighty three four hundred will
analyze the results on daily wire
backstage this Tuesday you are listening
to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so Bernie Sanders meanwhile
continues to be radical
it continues to be off-putting and his
people are basically now in full-on wine
mode because they think that everybody
is biased against Bernie
well maybe people just don't like Bernie
outside of sort of the core Bernie bros
because number one the Bernie bros are
kind of jerks and second Bernie's a nut
I mean like a full-on nut so Bernie
Sanders he had one of his advisors is it
gonna be mo Racha
and he and he came out yesterday he said
it's not just MSNBC biased against it
everyone is biased against us okay guys
it's not called a bias against you when
people finally start asking basic basic
questions about how garbage or candidate
is right it was biased for years when
they didn't ask those questions here was
Chuck Raja the Bernie 2020 senior
advisor on CNN complaining that
everybody everybody's mean to Bernie
stop being mean to Bernie guys what is
the heart of the issue that's been going
back months for several months now the
Sanders campaign has been charging MSNBC
with bias well look I don't think it's
just MSNBC we've worst we've won the
first three contests if you're watching
certain networks you would think we've
been behind and everyone because we get
very little coverage I just want to make
sure that the American people are
finding out all they can find out about
our movement about our people because
the people in the movement and raising
fifty million dollars 60 million dollars
from all these people are news and we
should be talking about changing
democracy in the way we fund campaigns
okay so first of all I'm pretty sure
everybody was talking about Bernie and
that was his big problem he had the same
problem that Bloomberg laws had which
was that he was unexamined then he was
examined and people were like oh don't
really like this very much Bernie's
continued burning continues to be a
radical idiot over the weekend he was
interviewed and again ripped into a pack
because it's a he's a very proud you
guys I mean I'm so sick of hearing about
how proud adju the guy is when he
repeats basic anti-semitic and ah strums
and it's like okay because he was born
into a Jewish family even though he
hangs out with blatant anti-semites all
the time like if this came out of her
shooter too liberal hun Omar's mouth
we'd all recognize exactly what it is
but because bernie is saying it we have
to pretend it isn't what it is here's
Bernie Sanders being an idiot
do you see a political cost in taking on
the pro-israel lobby in this way
yeah I do I mean they have a lot of
money they have a lot of power look I'm
Jewish and I'm very proud of my Jewish
heritage as a kid I spent time in Israel
I am NOT into anti-israel I will do
everything I can to protect the
independence and the security and the
freedom of the Israeli people but what
we need in this country is a foreign
policy that not only protects Israel but
deals with the suffering of the
Palestinian people as well is the first
of all he sounds terrible second of all
I mean when he's out there ranting about
the pro-israel lobby and how powerful it
is really because Nancy Pelosi refused
to even condemn Rashidah to leave in
ohan Omar and puts them on covers of
magazines by the way I never hear about
how powerful the pro Italy Lobby is or
the pro Britain lobbyists in the United
States I mean it's just it again this
sort of stuff has been sort of
stock-in-trade of left-wing
anti-semitism for a very long time and
the fact that Bernie traffic's in it and
then claims that he is a proud Jew
because he once spent some time on a
kibbutz when he was 17 back in 1322 is
is very is more than irrelevant to me
but bottom line is the more people see
of Bernie even inside the Democratic
Party the more that they are are wary of
Bernie as the nominee as well they
should be okay meanwhile president Trump
is having trouble with the economy
obviously the Dow Jones Industrial
Average seems to have stabilized a
little bit today basically it's seeking
a floor it jumped as of this morning as
people start to become a little bit more
confident the coronavirus isn't going to
be the be-all end-all uncertainty is
what led to that drop in in the stock
market last week that 4,000 point stock
market drop now everything is being
priced in the fact that there are
production delays the less information
that's out there the more people are
scared more people are scared the more
they sell more they invest in bonds so
all of the talk about how millions of
people would die due to coronavirus the
fact that the economic supply chains
were disrupted all that was being priced
into the stock market now it seems like
the stock market is finding a bottom and
when I mean that it's finding a bottom
it's kind of a sort of a stable floor
for the stock market as people readjust
earnings expectations for the year and
don't expect that there's going to be
any more massive and significant shocks
to the economy so all of that was
getting priced in very quickly last week
as people were sort of thinking worst
case scenario his coronavirus a real
crisis at this point the answer is
probably not the reason that I say
probably not is because
we now have some more information about
exactly what coronavirus is what it does
and what the risk factors are the New
York Times has quite a good piece about
this talking about sort of the facts on
coronavirus by denise grady comparing it
with the flu say coronavirus is deadlier
than the flu so far on average seasonal
flu strains kill about 0.1 percent of
people who become infected the 1918
Spanish flu had about a two percent
fatality rate and it was extremely
contagious early estimates of the corona
virus death rate from wuhan had been
around 2% but there was a new report on
1,100 cases from many parts of China
published on Friday in the New England
Journal of Medicine and it finds a 1.4
percent coronavirus death rate and as
the New York Times points out the corona
virus death rate may be even lower if as
most experts expect suspect there are
mild or symptom-free cases that have not
been detected also China's been lying
about this thing for months so the bad
news is that it may be incredibly
transmissible the good news is that it's
incredibly transmissible and not all
that many people are dying than your
death rate goes down so as the
denominator goes up meaning the number
of people infected and the numerator
stays stable meaning the number of
people who die the death rate goes down
the true the true death rate according
to the New York Times could be similar
to that of a severe seasonal flu well
below 1% that's according to an
editorial published in the journal by
dr. Anthony Fauci and dr. H Clifford
Lane of the national institute of
allergy and infectious disease as well
as dr. Robert Redfield director of the
Center for Disease Control even MSA
MSNBC's medical experts are saying
average Americans should not be panicked
about this thing it is not going to wipe
out vast portions of the American
population here is ms NB c--'s medical
expert i believe his name is joe fair
this is clip 19 now with the data we
have and i emphasize the data that we
have just because we haven't rolled out
broad testing and nationally yet your
average individual american doesn't need
to be that concerned right now of
catching this virus however community
based transmission in one state means
that there is probably community based
transmission and in other states once we
roll out that testing and lower the
criteria for being tested for Copco
vat19 we're probably going to see a lot
more cases than we thought we're here
previously
now again he's saying there are a lot
more cases that then we're here but that
means that they've been here for a while
and nobody's been noticing them because
we don't have vast swaths of the
population that have been dying out we
have two corona virus deaths total in
the united states apparently it was
going under
acted for weeks on end in Washington
State apparently is already been here
for a while and nobody's really noticed
it which doesn't suggest that this is
the Black Plague also again because
China's been so non transparent that
means that the figures on coronavirus
seem to have been exaggerated so for
example the New York Times reports each
person with the corona virus appears to
infect to point to other people on
average but that figure is skewed by the
fact that the epidemic was not managed
well ammu Han so everybody was infecting
each other and also on that time in
princess Cruz everybody was infecting
each other because they were quarantined
together right which means that
everybody is in contact with each other
regularly
who has the flu the figure for the
seasonal flu is about 1.3 the
reproduction number for the flu of 1918
was about the same as that of the new
corona virus but that was before modern
treatments and vaccines were both
available now there are no vaccines for
this virus yet but those are being
developed as we speak they're figuring
within 12 to 18 months there will be a
vaccine for corona virus that at least
lessens the impact of corona virus and
again they're sort of expecting this to
become just another strain of seasonal
flu here is the best news honestly about
corona virus is that corona virus and
flu it mostly affects people who are
older than 65 so that's obviously not
great news but the fact is that it's not
affecting people who are young and
healthy yeah the stuff that would be
truly scary is if young and healthy
people were dying off in vast numbers
from the flu corona virus seems to be
targeting and killing people who are or
at least affecting people
disproportionately who have a secondary
illness people who already have some
sort of lung disease people who are who
already have pneumonia right it's
killing off a lot of people who are in
that particular age group but apparently
it is not actually having a significant
impact on children particularly very
young ones which is honestly for me I
have two kids under the age of six like
that that's that's good news for me
especially because kids constantly have
their hands in their mouths they go to
these German factories where the
continent they're called schools where
they're constantly infecting each other
those cases tend to be extremely mild so
the Trump administration correctly is
saying we've been handling this thing
like please do not incite a panic right
President Trump came out he said listen
we've taken aggressive action against
this thing and any attempt to downplay
that aggressive action is just a lie
since the early stages of the foreign
outbreak my administration has taken the
most aggressive action in modern history
to confront the spread of this disease
we move very early that was one of the
decisions we made that really turned out
to be a lifesaver in a sense big
lifesaver on January 31st I imposed
travel restrictions on foreign nations
who had and anybody that had been to
China the people coming out of China hey
this is all true obviously one of the
things that is truly impressive about
the the about the media and the
Democrats is their reaction to all of
this maybe I'll save that for a thing
that I hate but okay well we gots it
let's let's do a quick thing I like and
then we'll get some things that I hate
so things that I like today so there
there's a great science fiction book
recommended new mutiny by producer Nick
who has time to read because we're not
apparently burdening him enough with his
work and he plays the banjo and he
whittles things and he reads science
fiction novels but that means that he
sometimes has good picks in terms of his
literary references Isaac Asimov's the
end of eternity it's a really good time
travel novel that fewer people know
about now than they probably should
everybody sort of knows the foundation
trilogy but the end of eternity which
I've never heard of is really quite
terrific it's a really well thought out
well plotted take on let's say in the
future there are a group of people who
could come back and change the past and
sort of change the past to avoid great
pandemics and and great nuclear
explosions and avoid all of the worst
things would that be a good thing or a
bad thing
the book is Isaac Asimov's the end of
eternity and worth the read okay time
for a big thing that I hate okay so
let's talk about the Democratic response
to the coronavirus thing so the
Democratic response the coronavirus
thing has been absolutely insane so as
we see president Trump has said listen
we've been handling this thing correct
and then President Trump came out he
said I'm asking the media not to incite
a panic all right we should not be
inciting a panic here at this of course
is exactly right as well the media
overplaying the risks of coronavirus in
an irresponsible way suggesting that we
are on the verge of a great pandemic
that's going to kill tens of millions of
Americans that the Trump administration
is botching it is politically driven
here's from saying that he's correct I'd
like to just ask and caution that the
media we would respectfully ask the
media and politicians and everybody else
involved not do anything to
incite panic because there's no reason
to panic at all this is something that
is being handled professionally yeah
that's exactly right with dr. Anthony
foul to use the head of the National
Institute of Health there are
accusations last week that because this
operation was being run through Mike
Pence the PR operation is being run
through the vice president's office
which is just trying to consolidate
information so you don't have vast
swaths of misinformation running around
foul she said listen I'm not being
muzzled the media tried to claim that
who's being muzzled he's like I'm not
being muzzled what the hell are you
talking about let me clarify it I have
never been muzzled ever and I've been
doing this since the administration of
Ronald Reagan I'm not being muzzled by
this administration
what happened which was misinterpreted
is that we were set up to go on some
shows and when the Vice President took
over we said let's regroup and figure
out how we're going to be communicating
so I had to just stand down on a couple
of shows and we submit for clearance and
when I resubmitted for clearance
I got cleared so I have not been most of
it all that was a real misrepresentation
of what happened okay if how she served
under President Obama as well he served
under multiple administration so he's
saying listen we're not hiding any
information or Alexei czar the Health
and Human Services Secretary says it's
pretty obvious here that people are
overreacting and treating this as a
massive crisis when it is not it is a
crisis for the factory production in
China it is not a crisis for the average
American you're seeing people who are
stocking up on masks by the way here is
the basic rule about masks and mats the
masks medical masks are designed to
prevent people from coughing in your
face for example but the reality is that
unless you have a high probability of
being coughed on by someone with
coronavirus it's not gonna serve you
well so you really should be allowing
the medical professionals who are gonna
be treating people who come in with
symptoms to have the medical masks at
this point you want to handle
coronavirus in your own life wash your
hands a lot don't touch your face a lot
that's pretty much all you can do and
again these symptoms of coroner's
particularly for people who are young
and healthy are not severe what you're
seeing is that it's really bad for like
old age homes nursing homes that sort of
thing here's Alex azar saying people are
overreacting we are trying to give the
American people all the information we
have when we have it so they don't think
there's secret information they're not
getting
that at least helps we say what
uncertainties we've got and as we
resolve them we try to go there for
overreacting
yes absolutely if people going out and
buying the face mask that's not
necessary in fact we need those masks
for the people who should be using them
which are health care workers taking
care of patients okay he's right that on
an on an individual level the masks are
not gonna help you then they may help
you marginally but for health care
workers they do make a very large
difference bottom line is that everybody
who actually understands the issue right
left and center is saying this is not
yet a crisis it doesn't look like it's
going to become a crisis Mike Pence says
that right my pen says the risk remains
low for the average American which is
true I mean just like the risk of dying
by flu remains fairly low for the
average American here's Mike Pence the
American people should know the risk for
the average American remains low mm-hmm
and they can be confident and after
three days I'm leading the president's
effort on the corona virus I'm more
confident than ever that we are bringing
a whole-of-government approach the
president has directed the full
resources of the federal government and
talking with governors around the
country particularly in states where we
brought people back home so Pence says
all of that then he says the same thing
on on Face the Nation with Chuck Todd
and Ord Meet the Press the truck todd
and chuck todd then proceeds to ask
whether he is b he's gaslighting him
right this is the attitude of the media
in the Democrats is we'll see is that
the Trump administration which again has
not mishandled this right there's no
evidence they've mishandled this there
is no evidence at this point that this
thing is going to become a major a major
crisis inside America's borders we have
very good health public health
facilities in the United States we are
handling this thing it doesn't matter
the media are proclaiming that this is a
crisis here's Chuck Todd asking if the
American people are being gaslight after
being informed after the American people
are informed by doctors on the left on
the right on MSNBC right by Falchi who
is the guy who's supposedly being
muzzled then nobody's being muzzled
the information is out there that we're
handling this her struck Todd asking my
pens if we're being gas-lit about
coronavirus what facts are there that
Democrats are doing this seems like
people are asking questions and they're
concerned about the fires this this
implies some sort of political
motivation which is kind of gross well
III will tell you there's been a lot of
irresponsible rhetoric among Democrats
and commentator who who is this on the
Left names
name sir well because this is just it
just feels like gas lighting please name
some names I'm a we're all big well-read
Rob big people here my name some names
there was a column in The New York Times
that's that by a prominent liberal
journalist it said we should rename at
the Trump virus okay that that that is
does that apply do all so that the
president would be bland Chuck this fire
began in China
okay well listen to Chuck's out there
your gas lighting me or gas lighting me
nobody has said this thing's so pens
then gives them a name and then he's
like well that's not everybody that's
not everybody okay I'm gonna give you
some names you ready here some names and
people who have been completely gas
lighting the American public about the
Trump virus and and how this is all at
the Trump's fault okay Elizabeth Warren
perfect example so Elizabeth Warren
comes out yesterday she says I can't
think of a worse person in charge of
this thing then Mike Pence right the
worst person you could imagine be in
charge of this thing as Mike Pence here
is here is Elizabeth Warren desperate
for attention with the crazy eyes and
everything over on MSNBC let me just say
that the vice president pence he is the
wrong person to be leading this he has
actually the one guy around who has
experience in dealing with a virus that
gets out of control only he's the guy
who went in exactly the wrong direction
he paid more attention to politics that
he did to science and that really
created a health crisis in his state of
Indiana I cannot think of a worse person
to put in charge of dealing with this
Corona box it's a disaster right it's
all a disaster it's a disaster because
we're putting and then you have Chris
Hayes frowning at it okay what did Mike
Pence do that was so bad he wasn't in
favor of needle exchanges for HIV okay
that is a very controversial public
policy the federal government should be
facilitating intravenous drug use okay
that is a very controversial policy that
that the taxpayer should be picking up
the the cost of people shooting heroin
into their veins okay that's pretty wild
stuff okay and then Elizabeth Warren had
another take if that take wasn't enough
she then tweeted out a picture is a Mike
Pence to tweet out a picture today we
had a very productive meeting of the
White House coronavirus task force in
the Situation Room
we placed additional travel restrictions
on Iran and we're increasing the travel
advisory to level four urging Americans
not to travel to specific regions in
Italy and South Korea okay and it's
basically a meeting of the cabinet you
can see very
members of the cabinet there and
including by the way ben Carson as well
as there's a couple other figures here
who are not white people yeah but why do
why would that possibly matter who cares
there's a coronavirus task meeting all
right this is about trying to figure out
how to stop coronavirus elizabeth warren
tweets out we're facing both the public
health crisis and a potential economic
crisis we urgently need top experts at
the table in public health of medicine
many of whom are women this isn't it
many of whom are women how it you name
some of the people who should be in the
room who aren't in the room see my first
reaction when I'm thinking task force
for coronavirus isn't I wonder how many
people have vaginas handling this thing
like that really is not even on my list
it turns out I don't care I want the
people who are going to help stop
coronavirus I love that Elizabeth
Warren's first take is well you know
that's a lot of white guys that's a lot
of men a lot of penises in that room
talking about coronavirus is there a
special female access to knowledge with
regard to coronavirus is there a
specific person who was barred because
of gender from this room like a lady
came in and she was like oh well you
know some woman came in she I I'm the
expert the world expert on coronavirus
and suddenly pens like I can't be in a
room alone with you because my work
because mommy says no my wife says no so
I'm sorry we're gonna have to deal with
coronavirus on our own like what the
hell is she talking about but Chuck Todd
says it's gaslighting to point out the
Democrats are doing this routine okay
another example so President Trump did a
rally at the rally he points out that
the Democrats are hoaxing the American
people about the Trump administration
blowing coronavirus he doesn't say
coronavirus itself is a hoax
he doesn't say that coronavirus itself
is non-threatening he says the Democrats
are lying to you about the Trump
administration miss handling this thing
and that the Democrats are lying to you
that you're gonna die from coronavirus
and that we're all a tremendous
tremendous risk from coronavirus the
data aren't there to support that here
as president from saying that and then
we'll see the Democrats lying about this
and then you'll see Chuck Todd lying
about the Democrats lying about this now
the Democrats are politicizing the
coronavirus you know that
they are politicizing it they tried
anything they tried it over and over
they've been doing it since you got in
it's all turning they lost it's all
turning think of it think of it and this
is that new hoax okay I mean that's just
so he says what's the new hoax the new
hoax that Democrats are making this into
a big issue that we blew it right okay
and he's right about this so Democrats
did that right then Biden comes out and
he and he falsely claims that Trump
called coronavirus itself a hoax here is
Joe Biden just completely miss reading
from statements in the dumbest possible
way I don't want to talk down the
possibility of us being able to do this
well but you know the idea that Donald
Trump said just several days ago this
was a democratic coax the wedding God's
name is he talking about what in God's
name is he talking about
has he no shame we're in a situation
where instead and III respect a vice
president Pence and has been being put
in charge but we should be hearing from
the scientists Trump did not call
coronavirus a hoax
Bloomberg then did the same thing right
Bloomberg comes out he says Trump called
coronavirus hoax he didn't he said that
you guys are lying about the impact of
coronavirus and that you are lying that
the Trump administration is blowing it
and then the media don't ask a follow-up
like where's the follow-up guys by the
way Facebook actually fact-check Michael
Bloomberg statements on this and even
Facebook was like um yeah that's that's
not true like I didn't take down
Bloomberg's ad over it because they
don't take down ads on the basis of
fact-checking which is the correct
policy but even they were like um this
is not right like Trump didn't call
coronavirus a hoax he just said that you
guys are lying about it here's Bloomberg
lying about it I find it
incomprehensible that the president
would do something as inane as calling
it a hoax which he did last night in
South Carolina he said that the
Democrats making so much of it is a
Democratic hoax not that the virus was a
home this is up to the scientists and
the doctors as to whether there is a
problem it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable are just lying about what
from said and then Chuck Todd it says to
Mike Pence well you keep saying that the
Democrats are criticizing you unfairly
are your gaslighting us the unbelievable
lies that will tell to get Trump are
truly Trump is not the center of the
universe I like Trump likes Trump but
you
loved front much more members of the
media the Democrats they love Trump
because it allows them to turn
everything into a story about Trump when
the story is not actually about Trump
okay so don't forget we want to hear
from you tell us who you think will win
the Democratic nomination by texting
either Biden Bernie Bloomberg Warren 283
400 on Tuesday night during our daily
wire backstage we'll analyze the results
alive again text either Biden Bernie
Bloomberg Warren two eighty three four
hundred we will analyze the results on
daily wire backstage this Tuesday we are
doing Super Tuesday coverage and even if
my wife is in labor I will find a way to
be part of that broadcast we will figure
this thing out together but today is the
day before Super Tuesday tomorrow is a
big day super deuces stay tuned we have
two additional hours of content coming
up later today or we'll see you here
tomorrow in preparation for Super
Tuesday I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis clever and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
why douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Rowe Romina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]